yesterday joe biden announced a 300
billion dollar plan to forgive 10 000
worth of student debt for every debtor
who makes less than 125 grand per year
and 20 000 for every debtor who paid for
college with pell grants now
the whole situation is a little bit
awkward for joe biden because four
months ago his speaker of the house who
was at the time trying to defend biden's
reluctance to forgive the student loans
admitted that the president doesn't have
any right to forgive student loans
people think that the president of the
united states
is this more on the subject and you ever
want to know will you let me know people
think that the president of the united
states has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone he can delay
but he does not have that power that
would has to be an act of congress
he does not have that power except for
what was that joe oh never mind okay he
has that power it's just like when fauci
flipped on the masks the masks are dumb
the masks are terrible they don't work
stop wearing the oh yeah never mind
they're great and you have to wear them
all the time it's very very awkward when
they have to pivot 180 degrees like that
it's also awkward for biden that the
money will disproportionately help
wealthy white people
as the liberal activist and young turks
commentator nina turner points out the
average white borrower is 12 000
in debt while the average black borrower
is a whopping 52 000
in debt and as the left-wing brookings
institution noted a full third of
student debt is owed by the wealthiest
quintile of households while only 8
percent of student debt is owed by the
bottom quintile but then again this is a
feature not a bug of the plan right now
joe biden is losing support among
college educated whites so very simple
calculation he is buying their votes
before the midterm elections which is
corrupt
sure
but it's also par for the course in
politics especially among democrats
going back to the days of tammany hall
and gangs of new york
the biggest problem with biden's vote
buying scheme is not that it's corrupt
it's not that it's expensive it's not
even that joe biden has no right to do
it
the worst aspect of biden's payoff
is that it is going to encourage more
people to go to college where they will
be treated to a heavily subsidized
four-year training camp to make more
docile and ignorant democrat voters i'm
michael knowles is the michael knoll
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the viskens
fan
who says youtube says dr science has
said masks are 100 effective and you
must be shut down and thrown into the
gulags for saying otherwise
then dr science retires then youtube
says but on the other hand
this is absolutely true if you question
us you are questioning science and
reality and truth itself and
oh oh it's over now okay yeah never mind
we're good go back to normal it's just
it's so transparent when they do that
poor pelosi how's she gonna answer that
poor pelosi she's going to have to say
the president does not have any right
until
yes until august 25th in the year of our
lord 2022 then the president totally has
that right i think we need to be able to
do things for ourselves we can't trust
these people running our country that's
why you've got to check out rock auto
right now head on over to rockauto.com
the value of your minivan pickup sedan
whatever you drive probably appreciated
pretty significantly last year
that's the silver lining amid all the
crazy supply chain stuff and the record
inflation means you got to take care of
your automotive investment keep more of
your money by buying the auto parts that
you need to maintain and repair your
vehicle at rockauto.com
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years
it's family owned super easy to navigate
catalog always reliably low prices no
gimmicks you just you're not going to
beat their price anywhere doesn't matter
the day of the week same prices for pros
and do it yourselfers i've told you
about my buddy i'm going to shame him
again my buddy who he really likes rock
auto but he was he was just feeling a
little loose one day he goes to the
brick and mortar auto parts store he
just wanted to get a part
they find the part finally they wanted
to charge him 400 bucks he pulls up rock
auto it was 150 on rock auto he said you
you scammers you're trying to rip me off
over here i'm going back to rock auto go
to rockauto.com get brakes shocks carpet
wipers headlights mirrors mufflers lug
nuts or any other part that you need
rockauto.com be sure to write knowles
k-m-w-l-e-s and their how did you hear
about his box so they know that we sent
you
there is no basis there's no legal basis
there's no real precedent for joe biden
to do this
in
american law and history so he's just
doing it he's just saying okay the
midterm elections are coming up we're
underwater on every single issue people
hate us we're losing a key demographic
let's just pay them off let's just buy
buy their support
and if anyone questions us about it we
will just engage in
what aboutism
what what about what aboutism what about
what about what about and say hey
the republicans they cut taxes so that's
when they cut taxes that's kind of like
us buying the votes of the
college-educated white students
the point
is this
there is plenty of deficit reduction to
pay for the programs cumulative deficit
i can play for the programs many times
over
i will never apologize ever helping
americans working working america's
middle class
especially not to the same folks who
voted for a two trillion dollar tax cut
that mainly benefited the wealthiest
americans and the biggest corporations
that slowed the economy didn't do a lot
for
economic growth and wasn't paid for
and racked up this enormous deficit
just as we've never apologized when the
federal government forgave almost every
single cent
of over 700 billion dollars in loans to
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses across the across america
during the pandemic
no one complained
that those loans caused inflation
a lot of these folks in small businesses
are working in middle class families
they needed help it was the right thing
to do
so the outrage over helping working
people
with student with student loans i think
he's just simply wrong dead wrong
so nothing joe biden said there is true
nothing whatsoever but biden said that
the tax cut under trump was only for the
wealthy people it was only for the
gazillionaires and the corporations
that's not true everybody got a tax cut
whatever you think of the trump tax cut
maybe you think it was good policy maybe
you think it was not great policy
everybody who's paying taxes got a tax
cut under trump unless you lived in blue
states because you couldn't deduct the
state and local taxes from the federal
anymore but that was a politically
genius way to punish the blue states and
i think it was a way to stop the blue
states from free riding on the federal
government anyway that's a separate
point his argument there doesn't really
make sense then he says it it was bad
for the economy it didn't didn't lead to
any kind of growth uh that's that's not
true at all
listen i wasn't all that long ago but i
seem to remember the trump years being
boom years people were getting richer
people were thriving under trump
economic growth outperformed
expectations it was great enter joe
biden what do we get we get record high
inflation 40-year record high inflation
and we get a recession that's so clear
to people that the only way that joe
biden could deny it was by changing the
definition of recession so that's just
completely made up
and then he went after trump for
giving financial assistance to the the
business owners whose businesses the
government forced to shut down
and then he's saying republicans didn't
warn about inflation neither of those
things are true at the time republicans
said this is a bad idea to shut down the
economy and then to just give money away
willy-nilly
but if you're going to shut down the
economy if you're going to tell people
you can't go to work
you've got to shut down your business
then i think the government has some
obligation
to help you out during that period of
time the government caused that problem
the government mandated that everybody
shut down
the government therefore can't leave
people high and dry
in that circumstance that would be crazy
and furthermore
when when the government comes in and
says hey businesses that we
intentionally destroyed we're going to
give you a little bit of a lifeline to
make it through the next six months or a
year or two years as it turned out to be
that seems to make a lot of sense to me
because you want the businesses to
continue because you want the economy
not to collapse
very different from hey
college students who we didn't make go
to college we didn't force to take out
these kinds of loans we didn't force to
study underwater basket weaving and
lesbian dance theory and anything else
hey you guys who took out way too much
debt
we're just going to give you some free
money which probably will just cause the
schools to raise the tuition as they've
been doing ever since the federal
government has been underwriting college
education but furthermore which will
just incentivize more people to get more
stupid degrees and not really get an
education but become just
docile democrat voters which is all
they're really after does that seem like
the kind of thing we want to incentivize
that we want to underwrite and do we
really want a situation where america in
america the majority of people do not
get a four-year college degree where
you've got
the country as a whole subsidizing this
degree for a minority of people who
statistically will make more money than
everybody else
does that make a lot of sense doesn't
make a lot of sense to me
the problem with this it's not the
corruption of the payoffs i mean that's
a problem
it's not how much money it's going to be
that's a problem
it's that we are incentivizing these
people to go to college i break with my
fellow conservatives on the college
point a lot
sometimes you'll hear conservatives say
college is dumb it's always dumb you
should never go that's not my opinion
sometimes you'll hear conservatives say
this and i hear this one all the time
they say look college is fine if you go
and you major in stem you know you go
and you major in engineering you go and
you study something that'll help you get
a job that makes sense but if you go and
study i don't know history or literature
that's crazy i have exactly the opposite
point of view there is no reason to go
to a four-year liberal arts college to
study a job that's not what the liberal
education is for liberal education i
think is a wonderful thing the point of
liberal education is not to learn a job
it's kind of the opposite
it's to not study anything that directly
relates to a job it's to study the arts
of freedom the arts that allow you to
make sense of your freedom and allow you
to cultivate your higher will and allow
you to suppress and educate yourself and
suppress that those base desires and to
be a free person
to be a free man to cultivate all those
things which you do through literature
which you do through math abstract math
not practical engineering which you do
through the sciences
which you do through literature which
you do through all i think that's
wonderful
my problem with college is not liberal
education my problem with college is
that increasingly it is
pretty much impossible to get a liberal
education on any campus in america
that's not what you get there
instead what you get is leftist
indoctrination
instead what you get is
four years of nonsense
and rather than suppressing your lowest
appetites and cultivating your rational
will usually you get four years of
misbehaving as anybody anybody who's
been to college recently knows
and then you graduate with a lot of debt
and no education and no practical job
skills and nothing that's the problem
all you really all you really graduate
with is a greater likelihood to vote for
democrats which is the reason that the
libs are doing this that's why it's a
terrible thing liberal education is
great i wish we could i wish i wish we
had a lot more of it there were probably
a handful maybe a half a dozen schools
in america where you can reliably get a
liberal education these days
and now with joe biden underwriting
underwriting four-year college the
problem's only going to get much much
worse
really really frustrating we've we've
got a real political fight on our hands
when you want to get ready for a fight
when you want to
fill up your belly get some iron pumping
through your veins you've got to check
out good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code knowles
regardless of what this administration
defines as a recession americans are
hurting in their wallets food and gas
prices are higher than i've ever seen in
my lifetime and i guess really ever in
america that's why i am super grateful
for my absolute favorite meat delivery
service good ranchers good ranchers
offers an inflation proof subscription
model that lets you lock in your price
the day you subscribe plus you can pause
your subscription for up to 90 days or
cancel anytime you want but you will not
want to it's it's just an insane deal
that they are letting you lock in your
price on this incredible quality meat
plus right now they're running a back to
school give back program with the goal
of donating 100 000 high quality meals
to children in need to help them out i'm
offering 10 lucky listeners the chance
to win 30 minutes with me via zoom on
september 30th you can ask me anything
there we're calling it a meet and greet
do you get that you get it it's a joke
it's funny meet and greet go to
goodranchers.com knowles use code
knowles at checkout you get 30 bucks off
plus free shipping subscribe lock in
your price and inflation proof your
meals for life you'll be automatically
entered to win 30 minutes of meet and
greet with me on september 30th the
offer ends august 31st goodranchers.com
knows use code knowles at checkout
does joe biden have the power to forgive
all this student debt
is he that's the question that
everyone's asking joe biden doesn't even
have the power
well what is he claiming is the power
he's saying that
a september 11th law called the heroes
act
gives the education secretary broad
authority to grant relief from student
loan requirements during specific
periods such as a war
or some other kind of military operation
or some kind of national emergency and
for very specific purposes including for
instance to address the financial harms
of a war or a military operation or an
emergency and then joe biden is just
completely perverting the meaning of
this 911 law to say okay well it's an
emergency now
yeah i woke up this morning i felt kinda
like it was an emergency so we're gonna
we're gonna pay off the student loans of
people that i want to vote for me
that's the heroes act for you
and and then you've got the
conservatives
the feckless conservatives on the other
side crying about how he doesn't have
the real power to do this
newsflash he does have the power to do
this
politicians have the power to do
whatever they can get away with
if you have lived through the last two
and a half years if you have lived
through the reign of dr fauci
and you don't get that i can't help you
you're not gonna make it does does biden
have the right to do this no
he doesn't the law doesn't give him the
right to do this the american tradition
doesn't give him the right to do this
joe biden's creator does not give him
some natural right to do this but does
he have the power yeah of course he does
two different things
this is where sometimes conservatives
and libertarians get a little tripped up
on the way our government works because
they say that's not in the constitution
this legislative body or this president
or this so-and-so doesn't have the right
to do it it doesn't have the power to do
that
yeah no he doesn't have the right he
does have the power
the way our politics works is that the
the people and the institutions with the
power exercise it
and it doesn't matter what that bill up
on capitol hill and schoolhouse rock
says and it doesn't matter what the
constitution says they're going to wield
that power so joe biden's going to wield
it it helps him politically
he's buying votes okay tail as old as
time
what are we going to do about that
what are we what are we going to do
about people who exercise power outside
of the the limits and and their right to
do so
very little usually
very little and it's why we've got to
take a much tougher line with them you
saw desantis do this with dr fauci who's
the most egregious example of some
technocrat taking more power than he
deserves and desantis is really
ratcheting up the rhetoric as dr fauci
is trying to avoid a congressional
investigation by republicans if
republicans retake the house and or the
senate as fouchy is saying okay listen
i'm going to speed up my retirement
table here you're all getting a little
uh tough in your talk on dr fauci so i'm
getting out of here okay please forget
about forget my name i'll be over there
on saying helena you've got
ron desantis ratcheting up the attacks
speaking as bluntly as i've ever heard
him speak
and i'm just sick of seeing him i know
he says he's going to retire someone
needs to grab that little elf and chuck
him across
[Applause]
this i really love this line from
desantis it's the right kind of rhetoric
it's extremely funny it's true
it's
evocative it really paints a picture it
is in a word
trumpian
okay this is why people are going to
elect desantis
and they're not just going to elect to
san if they elect desantis they're not
just going to elect desantis to talk
like this they're going to elect
desantis because they feel that he can
do it because he's he has wielded
political power
in florida
pretty effectively for a republican very
effectively and that's why the libs are
pulling their hair out and gnashing
their teeth and why they hate him so
much yesterday i talked about that
stupid desantis commercial where they
put him out and they made him look like
top gun they dressed him up like tom
cruise and they had him do a little soft
shoe to pretend to be top gun and they
called it topgov and it was just the
most cringe inducing thing ever i had to
go get surgery last night to get the
cringe off of my face
and i thought what are you people doing
you got the real deal here
ron desantis is the real deal you don't
need to dress him up in a clown suit and
have him pretend to be a movie star he
just can do it he can just wield
political power and that i think is what
conservative voters in particular are
craving right now
we've had enough of the show we've had
enough of the talk donald trump ran on
we don't want all these all-talk
politicians nothing politicians we want
people who can actually get stuff done
and that's true part of the reason he
was elected because trump was a
businessman right he'd gotten stuff done
in the private sector of the economy and
how that translated into politics it was
a little bit of a mixed bag though trump
did accomplish a lot of really great
things so people want to go further i
think on the right say no we enough of
this
well i'm a conservative so i never want
to use the government i know i'm i'm we
have no right to ever use the government
if you elect me i i solemnly swear i
will do nothing that's over that is that
is some if that was ever popular at all
that is deader than disco conservatives
want people to be elected to office who
will wield the power
justly wield the power that the people
give to them desantis i think is
demonstrating that it's very important
to do that kind of thing
because the the the unaccountable libs
in the technocracy have run amok and
you're seeing now this is the most
offensive thing they've done
since the dog days of covid and it
relates to covid
politico's got a headline out politico
is a great
way to take the temperature of the feted
dc swamp it is a very swampy liberal
establishment insidery kind of outlet
politico has a headline
breaking news
trump white house exerted pressure on
the fda for covid19 emergency youth
authorizations a house report finds
the report by house democrats examining
the pandemic says trump officials sought
vaccine approvals to sway voters before
the 2020 election
and there it is
there it is what we were predicting the
whole time
they're starting to turn on the vaccines
because
when we were told
that the vaccines are they're 100 safe
no risks whatsoever you're you're an
idiot conspiracy theorist you're a
murderer if you say there are risks
because you're discouraging people from
getting the jab
you're causing vaccine hesitancy which
is no one should hesitate as the vaccine
is totally 100 safe
and it's totally effective fauci
wallenski and biden they all said if you
get the vaccine you will not get covet
you can't contract it it defies science
no way sir no way jose
and you can't transmit it either
totally safe
totally effective and when that was the
narrative
trump deserved no credit for the
vaccines he didn't do anything he if
anything he was an impediment no it's
fouchy deserves credit no it's operation
warp speed that has nothing to do with
trump that's all the scientists deserve
this is amazing trump that guy was you
but now
now that we know
that the vaccine was a little bit less
safe than they told us
there are some there were some side
effects you know myocarditis and blood
clots and changes to women's menstrual
cycles and all the stuff they told us
couldn't happen that actually did happen
yeah that's okay not totally safe and
it's not yeah okay it doesn't really
like stop you from getting kovid
or stop you from transmitting kovid
but it's still it's still probably good
that you get it you know like for some
reason because of reasons or something
but uh now that it's a little bit it's
obviously a little less safe and less
effective than we were told it was
well now it's all trump's fault
it's all trump's fault he rushed it
through
can you believe this maniac rushed
through the vaccine
the 100 totally safe and effective
vaccine that's how you know
that as so many of us predicted
and as so many of us were punished on
social media where i had episodes of
this show taken down
which it's not just
like you know you post a little video to
the internet and oopsy daisy that one
gets taken down well no harm no foul
this is a very expensive show to produce
so you take a video down that's a that's
a major monetary punishment fortunately
i get to pass most of that along to
jeremy and ben but that's it they went
after content producers and punished us
in our wallets and silenced us and
sometimes banned people from the public
square entirely for saying
the kind of stuff that politico is
admitting right now the kind of stuff
that the libs broadly are admitting yeah
maybe it wasn't
maybe it wasn't totally safe maybe it
wasn't totally effective
expect more of this
and expect this to color the the entire
political narrative going into the
midterms and into 2024 and beyond
when a republican does something good
he will get no credit and the democrats
will get all the credit when democrats
do something bad
democrats will get no blame republicans
will get all the blame it's just the way
it works there is no way around that in
the liberal establishment
just accept it and recognize that you
can't believe a word that these people
say
this is just
old school
bare-knuckle brawl interest politics
whatever you thought about the alleged
neutrality of the public square whatever
you thought about the high-mindedness of
the scientific pursuits that have
nothing to do with partisan politics
whatever that's all fake that's all made
up whatever you thought about well the
politicians are reigned in by the
limitations of the constitution that's
not true these guys are just old school
gangs of new york thugs that are buying
votes and lying to you and pushing
very false narratives and sometimes
injecting you with stuff and lying about
what they're injecting you with and the
minute something goes wrong they blame
the other guy
you can't believe what you read not just
in the newspapers on social media too
it's why you got to go check out tuvu
right now go to
tuvu.com what does freedom
mean to you
it's time to take a stand and stop
feeding the big tech beast that wants to
cancel us and censor us and isolate us
from one another on social media you
have heard me talk about tuvu which is
the new subscription-based alternative
that weeds out the bots and the trolls
and all the invasive ads and algorithms
that make big tech so toxic
tuvu is the photo sharing community app
built on family values data privacy and
freedom of opinion it is time to move
our communities our families and our
churches to a better place online where
big tech is not pushing its agenda its
vice its addictive content and it's
damaging mental health material tuvu is
ad-free so they answer to you the
subscriber other social platforms place
more than 40 of ads in your feed
that's how big tech makes most of its
money selling those data to the
government to organizations into
companies on tuvu
you're not going to see that kind of
thing are you hesitant to try a new
platform for the next seven days only
tuvu is giving our listeners a free
annual membership when you go to
tuvu.com knowles get all the details and
your free annual membership for a
limited time only at tuvu.com
knowles tuvu.com knowles or look for
tuvu on google play or the app store
the walking back
of the of the supreme scientific and
medical confidence that you saw on the
masks that you saw on the social
distancing that you saw on the vaccines
that you saw in every aspect of covid
initially they told you oh it's all fine
it's all good no big deal absolutely
you've got to follow us and then it
turns out actually well it's not that
safe necessarily it's not totally
effective and the walk back that you are
seeing there you're going to see that
100 fold
1 000 fold
when it comes to transgenderism
we are being told right now that putting
little tiny kids on puberty blockers
pumping them full of cross-sex hormones
cutting the flesh off of their arms and
legs so that you can create a fake
looking phallus and and staple it on to
little girls ripping girls healthy
breasts off and just having a stream of
staples across their chests that that's
totally fine there are no side effects
it's reversible even no big deal let's
do it to little kids there's no problems
you are going to see
[Music]
an avalanche
of lawsuits you're going to see an
avalanche of disgust and regret when
people realize what they've done you're
already beginning to see that and when
that happens i promise you i promise you
the libs who are right now calling
conservatives murderers and phobes and
bigots and evil people for opposing this
stuff they're going to blame it on us
they're going to find a way to blame
trump for transgenderism they're going
to find and they're going to be find a
way to shuffle all the responsibility
for this psycho movement that they alone
are pushing they're going to find a way
to try to shuffle some of it onto other
people horrifying story right now
about this poor little 10 year old kid
little 10 year old boy who's got some
pervert psycho parents who are dressing
him up like a little girl and having him
strut down runways he's called the
youngest transgender
runway model in america's 10 years old
well his parents
or his
guardians or who knows what's going on
in this absolutely
dysfunctional family
the parents are saying that the little
kid is going to have transgender
surgeries starting at age 16. so not
just pumping him full of chemicals but
actually lopping off his body parts and
and in some cases lopping off his
healthy flesh on his arms and legs to to
mutilate him and make him look more like
the opposite sex allegedly
the youngest transgender model as as his
parents call him was socially
transitioned at the age of four
and had a legal name change by seven
because that's what he really wanted
because four-year-olds have bodily
autonomy and consciousness and can make
these kinds of decisions
don't forget according to our law a 17
year old can't consent to sex can't
consent to having a one-night stand a 17
year old but a four-year-old can consent
to lopping off his genitals according to
our culture
d mcmaher who is this child's mother
told the chicago parent in 2019 that
over the next few years the kid would
start puberty blockers and then begin
the physical transition
every reasonable person sees this story
and says
why why aren't these
parents in prison why isn't this kid
being taken by the state and given to
loving normal people or even put in an
orphanage he'd be better off in an
orphanage than with these child abusers
why why why when it's so clear
we have child abuse laws that's true
but this doesn't qualify a court it
would have qualified five years ago
certainly it would have qualified for
all of american history for all of the
history of civilization this would have
qualified as child abuse now though we
have a different conception of what
child abuse is because
we have accepted this this crazy idea of
transgenderism
in order for child abuse laws to have
force
we have to agree on what abuse is
and in order to agree on what abuse is
we have to agree on what is wrong and in
order to agree on what is wrong we have
to agree on what is good
and the conservatives even the
conservatives don't want to do it
the libs are willing to do it for the
libs it's really easy things that are
actually good they call evil and things
that are evil they call good that's it
there you go you've now had a master
class on the liberal conception of the
good
the leftist conception of the good
what about the conservatives though
there's a split
you've got the traditional conservatives
who say oh yeah well we know the good we
know we know what's evil we have reason
we can discern between these two things
we have revealed religion which also
helps us discern between these two
things but even just using our natural
reason we can know we can know it's
wrong to do this okay you don't need a
phd to do that in fact if you have a phd
you're probably more likely not to
understand that
conservatives get it but there's another
group
the kind of leave me alone types on the
right you do you and they're the ones
who will say well
who's to say what is good maybe your
good is my bad maybe my bad is your good
i don't want the collectivists to tell
me what's good i just want my own
conception because i am an island and
it's better to just be totally left
alone
and it leads to a kind of political
quietism that causes people to withdraw
from the political community and this is
what's crucial
refuse to exercise power
so what happens
you've got the libs who have a
completely inverted conception of what's
right and wrong
they're the ones wielding all the power
and you've got the conservatives
who say well i know it would be wrong of
me to exercise any power that would be
coercive that would violate my idea of
individual rights and i'm not going to
do that elect me and i'll do nothing
the government that governs least
governs best i want to shrink the
government down so small that i can fit
in my pocket that kind of stuff
that's why it's why by the way the libs
encourage
this conception of conservatives when
the the libs put a conservative into a
tv show the great example of this would
be parks and rec the kind of
curmudgeonly right winger is always
super libertarian
ron swanson he's always i just don't
want the government to to interfere in
anything whenever the libs are having a
straw man argument with the right they
always say i thought you're the party of
small government you're supposed to be
the party of of small government where
you don't do stuff stop getting involved
in my decisions and my rights they
always do that because it benefits the
left to have an opponent that refuses to
exercise power
because either way they win when the
libs win the elections then the libs get
to exercise power when the conservatives
win the elections then
the libs still get to exercise power or
nobody exercises power for a spell and
then the libs win again and then the
libs exercise more power
that's not a long-term strategy for
victory if you are on the right
we we have to exercise power to do that
we have to have a conception of the good
and we have to enforce that conception
of the good on other people which is and
it's better someone's going to do that
so it's either going to be our correct
conception of the good or the lib's
perverted one where they say it's good
to lop off the genitals of 10 year olds
well which one do you want to live under
you have to pick there's no neutrality
now you're starting to see conservatives
get this you're seeing this right now
down in texas the state government of
texas has just
done something that i have been hoping a
conservative state government would do
for a long time they have cut ties
with blackrock
with one of the largest
asset managers in the world
over blackrock's insistence on using its
tremendous wealth and and leverage and
power
to force
political institutions to go woke
and to force private companies to go
woke how does that what is blackrock
blackrock vanguard state street these
are the asset managers
that control trillions and trillions of
dollars
and they're they are one of the biggest
drivers of wokeness today
because they've got all those trillions
and trillions of dollars and look no one
ever elected black rock to any position
of power the people don't go to the
polls every year and say okay who what
do i support as my asset manager i let i
support vanguard this year no but they
just have a lot of money and money talks
and bs walks that's why joe biden is
buying votes right now because he knows
that that might help him in november and
it might help him in 2024. and so these
guys throw their power around and they
do it
explicitly in the political realm
so they do it to private companies
they make cracker barrels start offering
fake meat in their sausage not one
cracker barrel customer has ever
requested vegetarian sausage not one and
no one who has even walked into a
cracker barrel has ever contemplated
becoming a vegetarian and yet
cracker barrel now offers impossible
sausage why it's clear because the
biggest investors in blackrock or
vanguard and
in in cracker barrel rather are vanguard
and blackrock and they push this kind of
nonsense and part of that is pushing
vegetarianism and so cracker barrel
complies that's why and the companies
all know it but but these asset managers
also manage the funds of the state
pensions so they're getting involved in
the states in the political communities
and texas says no texas comptroller
glenn hagar says the environmental
social corporate governance movement esg
has produced an opaque and perverse
system in which some financial companies
no longer make decisions in the best
interest of their shareholders or their
clients but instead use their financial
clout to push a social and political
agenda shrouded in secrecy that's the
conservative political argument then
blackrock comes back the woke financial
manager and they come in they say
they say with their eight and a half
trillion dollars in assets they say
elected and appointed officials have a
duty to act in the best interests of the
people they serve politicizing state
pension funds restricting asset access
to investments and impacting the
financial returns of retirees is not
consistent with that duty
there's one word that i want to retire
from the english language it is the word
politicize
when we're talking about political
things you're politicizing education
you're politicizing state pension funds
yeah those things are by definition
political because they're yes obviously
a state pension fund is political it's
run by politicians that's right and the
people have a right to exercise some
power all blackrock is saying here is
hey you people have no right to govern
yourselves
wall street asset managers should be
governing all of you
under the guise of the free market no i
don't think so i don't think so
conservatives got hoodwinked by that
nonsense for way way too long and now
finally they're pushing back politicize
it baby bring on the politicization
you know for years we've been told that
above all else
we have to
trust the science listen to the science
i am science yet when it comes to
presenting any science to support the
safety of children taking experimental
puberty drugs to treat gender dysphoria
activists shrug it off they say science
we don't need no stinking science pump
those kids full of drugs the only thing
more appalling than the left's hypocrisy
is their willingness to sacrifice
children in some cases literally on the
altar of transgenderism and all their
crazy ideologies no film does a better
job of exposing the danger hypocrisy and
lunacy of the trans cult than matt
walsh's documentary what is a woman it
is already one of the most talked about
movies of the year everybody has watched
this movie if you haven't hurry up
the impact of this movie is continuing
to spread around the world let's keep
that momentum up by watching and sharing
the film at what is a woman dot com that
is what is a woman dot com
our problems politically
do not all come from socialism sometimes
you'll hear all these boomer
conservative types who say oh
socialism's on the rise it's all social
there everyone's a socialist no esg is
not a socialist movement
the dangers to our political order posed
by black rock state street vanguard
they're not it's not that they're
socialists
even joe biden paying off the student
debt it's not exactly socialism
it's more just like an old machine
politician buying votes
okay there are way more problems in
america than socialism
but
socialism is a problem too there is a
new york state senate primary winner
kristin gonzalez who just wants she won
her primary and she's celebrating and
she says that this victory is not just a
victory for her it's a victory for
socialism
i know we're saving the speeches for a
little later but today we really prove
that socialism wins
we are not going anywhere we are not
going anywhere and we will not stop
until we see a socialist slave across
this city
[Applause]
all these socialists look exactly as you
would expect they just there's just a
certain look to socialists especially
from new york and i think she's right
about socialism being on the rise it is
for
most of the 20th century certainly the
latter half of the 20th century if you
called yourself a socialist
that was
political suicide you were dead
the first one on a national scale to
really do it in many many decades was
bernie sanders and he was really
considered kooky he was the lone
socialist out there now it's much more
common aoc calls herself a socialist the
whole squad calls themselves socialists
you see it with a lot of other
candidates around the country there are
democratic socialist clubs on campuses
all over the united states i wasn't in
college all that long ago it was 10
years ago that was unthinkable even at a
super lib school like the one that i
went to now almost every campus i go to
including the conservative ones they
have a dsa chapter it's on the rise
there's no question why is socialism on
the rise
i think the reason is
because liberalism is unstable
the reason socialism is on the rise is
not because the kgb are sending agents
to american campuses
necessary or that china's sending agents
to america they actually are sending
agents to american campuses but
so that's
not just to spread the ideology of
socialism it's because liberalism is
unstable
and so you're seeing now that the two
parties becoming more polarized
well they are in a way becoming more
polarized because that squishy middle
doesn't make a lot of sense
liberalism is an ideology the new kind
the old kind the classical kind all of
it is unstable because it relies on all
the old good traditions that are
pre-liberal
all the old institutions that are not
liberal
the church and the family and the
township and the
and the
mores and the habits and the family and
the ways of life that are not liberal
in order to survive but liberalism
as a kind of rationalist ideology chips
away at all of those things
and so at a certain point you can think
of it as liberalism leaning on
tradition and society and the family and
the institutions and the church and all
of that and and as as liberalism just
starts eroding
its its support all of a sudden as those
institutions fall away liberalism
collapses and then you've got choices
you can either have
a conservative worldview
or you can go to the more extreme
side of of socialism but that's where
it's going to sort out
you're seeing that sort out happen right
now
and you're seeing it among a lot of the
left-wing libs they're becoming more
liberal more leftist more socialist and
among the right-wing liberals the kind
of libertarians or the classical
liberals or the people just call
themselves a right liberal they're
becoming much more
traditionally conservative
i think it was ever thus i think that's
the way it's going to happen
and you're going to see more socialist
candidates you're seeing one right now
in
pennsylvania
the democrat candidate in pennsylvania
is a socialist his name is john
fetterman he's not just being called a
socialist by right-wingers like me npr
calls john fetterman a socialist
and
john fetterman is doing relatively
pretty well for a candidate who's never
had a real job in his life who's mooched
off his parents and got an allowance of
over 50 grand
while he was pursuing his political
career john fetterman who
has terrible health he had a stroke on
the campaign trail disappeared from the
campaign
has never really answered any questions
about his health doesn't seem to be
paying for it he's doing really well in
the polls and he's running against dr oz
the tv host
and right now the republicans are
getting worried so sean hannity
has invited dr oz on his show to debate
hannity says
fetterman actually has a picture of me
and dr oz on my tv show so he's got to
stop hiding in his basement just like
joe biden and come on my tv show he goes
and then
or on his
tv show or his radio show i guess he
invited him
he says then you can explain the
positions that you've taken over the
years and your lazy lifestyle and how
you lived off your mama and your data
and how you bought your sister's house
for a buck and your positions on heroin
and everything in between so i i think
that would be good i would be happy if
sean hannity debated john fetterman
but it's kind of sad that hannity has to
do this
because dr oz should be doing this
and the problem is dr oz is running a
terrible campaign and i want dr oz to
win
he wouldn't have been my choice in the
primary
because he's a democrat and he was he
was defending uh abortion and attacking
pro-lifers not that long before he
decided to run for senate as a
republican but okay you go to war now
with the army you want with the army
you've got i would much rather have dr
oz in the senate than john fetterman so
i really want dr oz to win
i'm not i'm not really attacking oz
to hurt oz i'm attacking oz's campaign
because his campaign is being run very
poorly right now
oz needs to be doing this he can't go
out and have sean hannity fighting all
his battles for him he's got to be a
better candidate and he's got to have
better campaign staff and i don't know
whoever we played that extremely stupid
dr oz commercial the other day whoever
made that commercial needs to be fired
and probably thrown in prison because of
how bad it was and he just has to do a
better job
because i really don't want this
socialist to be in the senate
and he's just not oz just made another
gaffe or his campaign just made another
gap
jon fetterman has been attacking dr oz
over a really stupid campaign
commercially made a while ago where it
was him walking through a grocery store
not even correctly identifying which
grocery store it was because dr oz
obviously doesn't do his own grocery
shopping and he was walking through
picking up vegetables and he said he was
picking out vegetables because his wife
wanted to have a crew detail platter
yeah nothing appeals to blue-collar
workers in the rust belt like crude tape
ladders
and then he's talking about crew detail
and how the price of vegetables has gone
up at the grocery store the name he
can't recognize and the campaign
released that
that's not
that's not john federer's fault that's
not even really dr oz's fault that's the
campaign's fault whoever put him in that
position
was running a stupid campaign and
fetterman's been hammering him on it and
now oz is getting angry and oz responds
and says if jon fetterman had ever eaten
a vegetable in his life then maybe he
wouldn't have had a major stroke and
wouldn't be in the position of having to
lie about it constantly that was the
senior communications advisor to the oz
campaign and you know that line is super
funny i'm not going to deny that that's
a hilarious line but it's really mean
and really bad politics that doesn't
make dr oz look good that doesn't make
jon fetterman look bad
if anything it makes me more sympathetic
to john federer you're making fun of a
guy for having a stroke
that's not ah there's so many things you
can hit the guy on there's so many ways
you run this campaign jon fetterman is
just a total loser i mean this guy is
such a terrible candidate
and yet
the republicans are blowing it
they're blowing never underestimate the
ability of the republican party and the
republican party leadership and
consulting class
to steal defeat from the jaws of victory
never under i hope they turn the
campaign around i really really hope
that they do now as a little palette
cleanser to that to make me feel a
little bit better
speaking of congressional politics
there was just a brutal primary in new
york
because of redistricting in new york
because the democrats took their eye off
the ball
they ended up in a position where new
york lost a congressional seat
and you had
two sitting congressmen
have to duke it out
and the two that had to duke it out were
two of the longest serving most
prominent democrat congressman in new
york jerry nadler
and carolyn maloney
and jerry and adler won
he won by a lot jerry nadler won 55 to
24.4
these guys had been in the house for a
combined 60 years
when they're both just awful
it's sort of like the iran-iraq war you
just wanted both of them to lose
when maloney lost she blamed sexist
systems and misogyny
she said i'm really sad we no longer
have a woman representing manhattan in
congress okay bye see you sister later
and then nadler won in the way that he
explained his win is he said i think
carolyn and i have worked on a lot of
things together but i think i have a
more principled progressive record she
voted for war in iraq speaking of the
iraq war i voted against it she voted
for the patriot act i voted against it
she voted for the iran deal i voted
she voted against the iran deal i voted
for the iran deal
so
nadler won okay someone had to win i'm
glad at least one of them lost that's
sort of nice the the lesson to take here
though is one right now
clearer politics are going to
win the day a more clear political
vision is going to win the day
so nadler wins by running to the left of
maloney and also wedge issues reminds
you here there are wedge issues in every
party for every political group the
issues that split your own side
those are the issues to focus on when
you're running against
democrats
you well now the iraq war is kind of
dated but you could use the iraq war
issues that
whatever republicans think of it will
split the democrat vote democrats are
very good at using wedge issues
republicans a little bit less so before
i get to the member block by the way
i've got a very important political
issue that we've got to get to
kim kardashian is making headlines as
she always does this time for bringing
back a hairstyle that apparently was
gone
the the
pop culture magazines are alleging that
kim kardashian is bringing back the side
part
so not partying here in the middle party
and on the side i would just like to say
because you know i hate to say i told
you so and i consider myself something
of a profit and predictor of these
things i have had a side part
since i was about three years old
okay i have had the side part much
longer than kim kardashian and so if the
side part is coming back i would like to
think that it is because i am the setter
of fashion
and a fashion icon actually uh and uh
in this way i think more influential
than kim kardashian you know she's had
the center part for a long time i had
the side part who's responsible for this
trend coming back i don't think it's i
don't think it's complicated the rest of
the show is going to continue now you do
not want to miss it
if you are not a member uh then you've
got to become a member this is not for
the hoi polloi okay you know that uh
when we're here in public when we're on
the podcast apps when we're on youtube
and everything we've got to be a little
careful with the way that we talk you
know we got to use sometimes euphemisms
dance around things when we go to the
member block you're getting just pure
unvarnished
levels of koffe you know you're just
getting the real deal so make sure you
head on over click that link we'll see
over there
[Music]
[Music]
you